[Music]
chuck got another one i keep bringing
him if you keep listening i'm going
what else am i doing today you just turn
around and exit the room i'll stop
talking about it all right that sounds
good well we're gonna be talking about
these for a long time man
i got one yeah
have you ever met
leo mio and geo
you know i don't think i want to uh
i don't they don't sound like good
people like friendly people they don't
sound like good people you know leo
yeah exactly
hey how are you doing listen i got a
message from leo mio and gio
all right
we understand that uh perhaps you are
not cooperating with the fact that uh we
are protecting your organization
[Laughter]
somebody watching grew up on tv and
movies and but never read any books
that's what that is
all right so these are these are orbits
around earth and they've been
abbreviated playfully but
but legitimately
and so if
you
go
not too high above earth's surface right
so
anywhere between zero and a couple
hundred miles okay right a few hundred
miles
and you say i wanna orbit the earth
there is a speed that you have to attain
in order to accomplish this right okay
isaac newton first drew this picture
where he imagined sort of a mountain at
the top of the earth like the north pole
right that's not important here it's
just on there's a mountain there and you
have a projectile being sent out
horizontally right from that mountain
you say well where does it land well it
lands a little farther it's a projectile
so the lands a little farther away
from where it got shot out of the cannon
but suppose i shoot it faster
it'll land even farther away
faster even farther and as it does this
it begins curving
along with the curved earth
you can picture this because gravity is
pulling it down
he imagined that there must be a speed
with which you can send that projectile
so that it goes completely around the
earth and hits you in the back of the
head
right
that speed
is orbit
and once you've achieved that speed as
long as you duck
it will continue in orbit without any
extra support
okay so what's happening is this object
is falling towards earth
in what we say free fall it's falling
towards earth at exactly the rate
that the curve of the earth
pulls away from it
so i fall five feet towards the earth
but i'm so far down range that earth is
curved five feet away from me right
so i
keep the same distance above the earth
even though i'm falling towards the
earth this was the brilliant revelation
of isaac newton back in 1687.
god was kind of smart i got to give it
to you he was kind of smart and
principia mathematica the mathematical
the full title is the mathematical
principles of natural philosophy it's
just abbreviated principia but k is a c
sound it's the latin hard c principia so
so so there you have an orbit if you do
that within a few hundred miles
that orbit
to achieve that you have to go about
five miles per second
okay
so in one second
the amount of distance you have fallen
towards the earth equals how far earth's
curvature is curved away from you gotcha
all right so about five miles it's what
is that that's uh
25 15
uh 12 carry the two
uh 18 000 miles an hour okay so if you
go 18 000 you will sustain orbit in this
low section of earth of
earth orbital space and we call it low
earth orbit spelling leo leo all right
leo all right now you wouldn't want to
do that too low because you're moving
within the atmosphere right and you
don't want to hit yourself in the back
of the head and you don't want to hit
yourself no so so you go high enough so
the atmosphere is thin enough so you can
sustain this without the air dragging
you back down to earth okay so that for
that you got to go up you know at least
100 to 200 miles space station is
orbiting 260 miles or so the hubble
telescope is orbiting 350 miles or so so
that's all in the low earth orbit regime
if you do the math 18 000 miles an hour
it takes about 90 minutes to complete an
orbit
if you are in a spaceship at that
altitude at that speed
you will see
how many 18 sunrises and sunsets uh so
in the 24 hour period okay so it's very
cool very cool all right so that's leo
go up a little higher
okay
600 000 miles it might go a little
higher than that you get middle earth
orbit
it has nothing to do with tolkien just
want to make that clear
and lord of the rings all right right
there no middle-earth creatures orbiting
the earth that we know of mr frodo
mr
frodo stay with me i'll get you to the
satellite i promise
[Laughter]
so
so a middle-earth orbit those
are all of our gps satellites are
orbiting there for example okay
so the higher your orbit is the longer
it takes you to complete an orbit
okay okay because you're moving slower
and slower and the distance is getting
bigger and bigger
you know the circumference of your orbit
right all right so as you ascend it'll
take two hours four hours eight hours 10
hours 15 hours you keep going
there is a magic distance
where it will take you exactly as long
to orbit the earth
as earth takes to rotate wow
so it takes earth
23 hours 56 minutes and four seconds to
make one full rotation on its axis okay
find the distance
where that's how long it takes you to
make one orbit
and you will appear to hover
over the earth
oh that's that's the most boring orbit
of all
it's not getting anywhere who wants that
one okay it's the most important but
it's the most
it's the most useful
orbit ever conceived okay and this was
written down by arthur c clarke in 1946
1947 and it's where he said now that we
have rockets because the war and the v2
got created um right in right in my back
you know right out
a couple of years ago what are we going
to do
with these rockets now that we have them
and are we going to make satellites if
we do imagine having a satellite in one
of these orbits and parking it
over the atlantic between europe and the
united states
then you can take a radio signal from
europe beam it up to the satellite and
send it back down to the united states
and enable you to communicate across the
curvature of earth's round surface
that's right there you go that's
absolutely brilliant thus was born
the communication satellite
and we were in the in there early
telstar was our first communication
satellite and we knew where to launch it
and what it would do and how it would do
it and you and i are old enough to
remember you'd see news stories and it's
a live via
satellite that's some modern stuff going
down there um so this is um
geostationary orbit so we just call it
geo
that's how you get leo mio and geo there
you go
now there's something else called
geosynchronous orbit right a
geostationary orbit is a special case
of a geosynchronous orbit because if
you're synced with our rotation you can
have an orbit for example where
you go around twice
in the exact time it takes earth to
rotate once
that's synchronized two to one
or three to one or five to one if you're
synchronized in any way you can you get
to call it geosynchronous
but if you want to be parked
you have to be geostationary gotcha and
that's where they want to put the space
elevator you might have heard of this
okay reducing the cost of access to
orbit right
if you have a place parked over the
earth
why not just lower a rope and then climb
up the rope you don't need rockets well
that guy got a hay in gym
climbing the rope that's for sure so by
the way i knew i was badass in gym when
i can climb the road without using my
legs
oh so you get upper body enough upper
body strength against your own body
weight to do that
i said wow okay that's i think that's
no i did it because i had to it was like
part of the unit but when john claude
does it that you know he could use his
legs he chooses not to for for the movie
right right so
uh the point is you when you're
geostationary you can park a platform up
there
lower a rope and just have elevators go
back and forth leo is a couple hundred
miles mio is a
high hundreds into low thousands and geo
stationary orbit is about 23 000 miles
up oh i know that's a long elevator ride
i'm telling you right now you better
pack a lunch for that elevator and you
need and you need
really good elevator
space elevator music
[Laughter]
music for the stars yeah not girl from
empanema i know
that ain't gonna work
is that on every elevator
it's like the elevator cliche trophy
you get in the elevator ding doo doo doo
so so there you have it i don't know if
you thought about it every care about
leo mio and geo but
in addition to however you're
fantasizing them
to be
sort of uh collectors of money
[Laughter]
people who doing right by the shark
loans right
these are actual places in orbit around
the earth
so we just want to let you know that
this is how it's going to work okay
leo leo's gonna come by for a minute
all right
and and and geo is gonna be looking at
you would that know where you are listen
geo is always gonna be here okay
just in case you get any ideas
okay just know that uh you know you
might see leo pass on okay
and uh you know meal might come by and
stick around for a minute but geo you'll
never see him
but he's always he's always looking
and by the way so that's where we put
all the all the
the communication satellites if you want
to monitor one part of the earth you
would put a satellite there
and
by the way if you were going to destroy
a satellite for whatever reasons it's
happened three times on purpose oh okay
china did it first then we did it then i
think russia did it somehow the third
country did it our satellite that we
destroyed was in was in uh leo
low enough so there's enough air
molecules just to slowly slow it down so
it can be dragged back down and if you
slow down at all
it means you fell to a lower orbit where
there's even more air molecules to slow
you down even more
so it's a runaway process
runaway collapse and usually drop them
into the atlantic ocean to the pacific
ocean uh which contains one third of all
the world's longitude it's the big
toilet bowl of
so normally you do that if you were done
with a satellite you have a little bit
of extra fuel to deorbit and drop
yourself in the in the pacific but if
you destroy a satellite it's just
fragments and you don't really control
them you just hope they burn up
re-entering the atmosphere whereas the
stuff that china did it made a complete
mess and it's still the stuff is still
up there and this happened like a decade
ago wow
you know what see people this is what
that's what happens that's a decade of
two decades this happened in like 2000
early 2000s i think wow so things to
consider as we move forward thinking
about space security space as a backyard
space tourism this all matters
yeah yeah and there are more debris
particles in those three orbits than
there are
satellites that are put there on purpose
so it's quite the mess and i joked that
aliens did come by wanted to land they
looked at the debris field they said
no sign of intelligent life here
let's go back to those slobs it's the
total slot
yeah tell me about it look at these yeah
we're basically uh the equivalent of
having a car up on blocks on your front
lawn
that's what we look like today
[Laughter]
it's all right that's all i got to tell
you here on leo gio and mio i like it i
love it there's a story of leo mio and
geo you got it yeah another three wise
men of
our planetary orbits orbits
so this has been another star talk
explainer neil degrasse tyson here
always good to have you chuck always a
pleasure all right as always
keep looking up
[Music]
you